foreign
[Music]
how long will you be staying I don't
know where are you staying no idea any
drugs or alcohol no
[Music]
unanimous
wanted to spend a little time with my
grandson that's what it's all about
you're not supposed to smoke here what
it's a glaive and no he doesn't
run around like a kid and you're not a
kid anymore you're a man ow you know I
think I turned out okay right oh you
live with your mom all right she lives
with me okay but I pay the mortgage
you run away from people who love you
nothing is as important as family do you
know what it's like people constantly
ask you about your brother
foreign
lead a quiet life
no I try to do nice things yeah they
still think I'm like a joke
I just want like a regular type butt
we're in comedy you've got to be able to
walk away from anything in your life in
30 seconds flat that's why I got nothing
tying me down
do you have a kid oh yeah
[Music]